hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today we will be reviewing fitness
youtuber and influencer sami clark
okay so first let me tell you about my
sponsor ava's manor
which is free to download using my link
below ava's manor is a mobile game
available through google play or the
apple app store
it's got a bunch of levels of solitaire
tri peaks to earn stars
which are used to progress through the
story and to renovate and decorate the
rundown manner
if you're into interior decorating
without the crazy expenses
it's really fun to pick out all the
decor
and furniture in the house and the
gardens and then like
personalize the space with your own
style when you just want to unwind
after a long day i find it's a nice
change from like
mindlessly scrolling online and i
actually find i get a lot of really
great interior design inspiration as
well
i find the puzzles are challenging
enough to keep you stimulated
without being overwhelming and
frustrating
so now you get to work both your left
brain and your right brain
at the same time so if you want to learn
more about avis manor and download it
for free
check out the link in the description
below now as always you can pause the
screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with previous
or current experiences with disordered
eating i will as
always be talking about calories and
macros
so of course feel free to skip that
portion
if it isn't supportive to your journey
and of course don't forget to subscribe
to this channel
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a episode
and as always a heads up i'm filming
this ahead so this is the most
recent what i eat a day on sami's
channel at the time
of filming but of course it may not be
an up-to-date example of her diet so
as always use this more as teachable
material for the general population
not necessarily specific to sammy right
now
today all right let's get into it one
cup of water
and a half a cup of oat milk a half a
cup
of gluten-free quick oats a teaspoon of
vanilla extract and i'm gonna chop up
some bananas
while i wait
okay so this looks delicious
we've got a good solid amount of
energizing carbs and fiber in the oats
and banana
plus we've got some protein and fat in
the hemp hearts and
peanut butter and we've got chocolate
and if
that is what gets you out of bed in the
morning i am here for it
now for a pre-workout meal this is
literally
perfection to me and i'm sure it's a
pretty
satiating breakfast as well let's see
what's next
for my smoothie i'm going to do
blueberries add a dash of some almond
milk i'm also going to add some vanilla
protein powder
handful of frozen spinach
okay so that looks like a great
post-workout
snack or smoothie we've got protein in
the protein powder and collagen powder
and carbs in the blueberries and banana
now i've got no clue what brand of
collagen she's using so
this could vary a lot but i would say
that the combination of
protein powder and the collagen powder
together
possible overkill now while we do have
some emerging research to support the
use of collagen powder for skin
hair joint health and bone health a lot
of these benefits
would be found from adequate protein
from
any source so like her protein powder
in other words our collagen needs can be
made in-house
from the amino acids in the protein
powder and vitamin c
in the produce in her smoothie now this
smoothie also comes out to almost
40 grams of protein and about an equal
amount of carbs
so i'm not denying that getting in that
extra protein can
definitely help promote satiety and also
just help sami
get in enough total calories for the day
but when we talk about sports nutrition
and post-workout fuel
we would ideally want to see a greater
emphasis
on carbs so maybe throwing in another
banana
or some oats or pairing this with like a
slice of toast
we also ideally want to spread that
protein out more evenly
for maximal muscle protein synthesis now
most of the literature suggests
around 20 to 30 grams max at a time and
there's obviously a lot of variables at
play
having said that sami did say that she
usually has her collagen in the morning
with her coffee which
i agree would probably be a better way
to
space things out in an ideal world but
this is super
nitpicking and i'm only saying this
because she is
a fitness influencer and obviously i
would assume
that sports nutrition is important to
her let's see what's next protein
powders is something that i have
struggled with trying to find because
they can be really harsh on your
digestive system i would bloat
really really bad or i would get insane
stomachaches these are my brands
right now that i love that do not give
me a stomachache and really are clean
one is one called new zest that one is a
little bit of a cleaner taste you do
have to add more sweeteners
to cover up the taste if that makes
sense two is
a protein powder called high protein hi
it's so clean
that i wish there was a little bit more
sweetness to it and then we will see how
this one goes
it is a whey protein he was saying how
he concentrates it out
that he strained it all that there's no
dairy actually
in this product so it's um dairy free
that's what i'm trying to say
okay so i don't love the whole
clean rhetoric obviously but i assume
she just means it has fewer ingredients
like artificial sweeteners and flavors
and colors etc
as it sounds like she has a sensitive
gut now later
on in this video she does an update and
she says that
this particular protein powder that
she's using which is a whey protein
isolate powder didn't upset her stomach
like other whey protein powders
have now she does a pretty good job
explaining why this
is but in case it's unclear to anyone i
actually have a whole video unpacking
different protein powder options right
here but in short
whey protein comes from dairy and it's
bound up with some
lactose and fat now whey protein isolate
is refined more aggressively than whey
protein
concentrate which is the cheaper option
and as a result it's slightly lower in
lactose and higher in protein now i
can't speak to this particular brand
that she's using because
at the time of filming there was
actually no information on their website
about it
but generally speaking wave isolate has
around 23 grams of protein
and up to 1 gram of lactose per serving
while whey concentrate has
about 18 grams of protein and up to 3.5
grams of lactose per serving
so while sammy describes this protein
powder as
not containing dairy it does contain
dairy
it's actually made from dairy but it has
a very very small amount of lactose in
it
which may make it more tolerable if
you're lactose intolerant
which it sounds like she might be if
you're just starting out and trying to
eat healthier
i would say have realistic goals is the
biggest thing
one thing is to only try
one to two new recipes a week
when looking for recipes keep it simple
like when you're looking them up on
pinterest or instagram
find ones that the ingredient list is
this big
not this big so i think these are really
awesome reasonable and sustainable
healthy eating tips i think it's really
easy to scroll through instagram
and feel super overwhelmed by
influencers seemingly taking like 45
minutes to an
hour to prepare an elaborate breakfast
every day of the week and you're over
here being like
hey i'm just happy if i ate
anything at all i see you and you know
most days i am also
just like struggling to cook meals from
scratch so i think setting a goal to try
a new recipe and also a simple recipe
is a really good realistic place to
start i made
chickpea pasta and chickpeas i didn't
really connect the dots in there so i
can't have gluten i
went with my chickpea but i probably
should have gone with like gluten-free
mac and cheese i'm gonna add them into
the pot and let them heat take a handful
of arugula
add some lemon and slightly drizzle a
little bit of nutritional yeast and
some olive oil and i'm going to add this
pesto sauce
okay this looks so delicious and yeah
even she picked up on the fact that
she's having chickpeas on chickpeas
and that isn't the most varied option
but hey
like that is okay not every meal needs
to feature
20 different ingredients to be
nutritious and
balanced it's really about the overall
weekly or even monthly picture that
matters more to me
so for folks who are cooking for one or
two it doesn't often make financial
sense to have
a million different proteins and a
million different vegetables and carbs
in your fridge at any one time
so if you're doing batch meal prep to
save time and money
my suggestion to promote variety would
be to choose
one or two different veggies fruits
grains and proteins to focus on each
week
and then rotate week by week as for the
meal itself
you guys know i'm a big fan of chickpea
pasta to
you know bump up that protein and fiber
in a pasta meal
and this looks absolutely awesome to me
we've got
protein and fiber in the chickpeas and
the pasta fat in the pesto
and olive oil plus veggies in the
arugula
i also love the addition of nutritional
yeast for that little bit of extra b12
and protein as well
honestly nothing i would change so
chickpea it up girl
[Music]
you guys know the drill your girl does
not critique
coffee but also even though i'm like
halfway through my second coffee of the
day
that looks really good right now but
there was also like this one of my
favorite restaurants called
the hive i was like okay i kind of want
to try the bone broth and i have not
tried like drinking bone broth
and you guys it is rough
i like truly appreciate when a wellness
influencer
straight up comes out and says nope
to some kind of popular wellness trend i
also sometimes have a hard time wrapping
my head around the flavor
and texture of bone broth i mean
sometimes i'm in the mood for it
but psychologically it usually feels a
bit like
drinking super salty savory tea
it's weird i think i've had some texture
to it with like noodles and veggies as
you would in like a bowl of soup
i would totally be damn i don't know i
guess i have to be like
really really hungry and or freezing
to want to drink it just on its own
anyways let's see what's for dinner
feeling extra lazy
perfection this is textbook balanced
meal
and i love how easy it was for her to
put it together
so we've got protein a healthy fat in
the salmon fiber in the asparagus and
carbs in the rice also like a week
before i watched this video i also
started to do
everything bagel asparagus like she did
here and it is one of my all-time
favorite sides right now so i am picking
up what
sammy is putting down i also love the
shortcut frozen
cooked rice i mean in the name of
simplifying meal times
i am all for incorporating at least
one kitchen shortcut into every meal so
whether that's pre-bagged salad
a frozen side dish rotisserie chicken
bottled salad dressing whatever if it
helps you get a balanced meal on the
table
quickly i think it's a good idea
[Music]
i feel like all these influencers are
low-key obsessed with this
who chocolate or hu chocolate i'm not
exactly sure how much
sammy ate here but in another video i
watched of hers
she did say that she generally has like
one
square so i guess if that is how she
likes to end her meal
works for me but for somebody who
apparently
struggled with acne should sammy be
having
chocolate every single day well as i
discussed in my
full video on the best and worst foods
for acne right here
contrary to the popular belief there's
actually
not a whole lot of good research to
suggest that there's
anything special about chocolate when it
comes to
acne risk one review of the literature
found
a very weak association between
chocolate and acne
but they also found a number of major
flaws in the research study designs
most significantly that a lot of the
studies to date
have not controlled for the type of
chocolate used in their experiment
and that's kind of important since we
know
that both sugar and dairy products
can play a role in acne and of course
milk chocolate candy bars
are higher in both of these things
compared to a
high quality dark chocolate so assuming
that she's sticking to
a good high cocoa content chocolate bar
like the ones from
who she's probably in the clear so on
that note
let's break down the stats and of course
a trigger warning
i'm about to talk numbers so please feel
free to skip to the time stamp on the
screen
if this is triggering for you so
according to my calculations
sami is consuming around 2 200 calories
with 25 of calories from protein 39
from carbs and 36 from fat
and when i ran this day through the
chronometer i can't see that there was
really anything
problematic or missing so it seems like
she's pretty in tune with what her body
needs
i might suggest a wee bit more carbs
since she
is so active in her job but if
this macro split feels good to her it
works for me
let's talk about what i like here
honestly
i like a lot it's really nice to see a
fitness influencer
not chronically under eating not
explicitly restricting carbs
fats or oils not demonizing certain
ingredients and foods
and not restricting whole food groups it
sounds like sammy has
health reasons for limiting gluten and
dairy in her diet and it probably took
some experimenting for her to
come to a conclusion that removing them
from her diet was what was going to feel
best for her
i also love that she is all about making
healthy eating
simple and sustainable her recipes are
easy to follow
quick and of course outside of some of
the supplements that she uses
which i don't think are excessive she
focuses on
readily available whole food ingredients
plus
everything looks super delicious and
really well balanced
i mean the girl clearly knows her stuff
in terms of gentle nutrition tips i
really would have to
dig deep to come up with any major
recommendations for sammy
like i said i think she really is very
much in tune with her nutritional needs
and also what feels good to her body
and what doesn't so if gluten and dairy
are not working for her
whether that's for digestive issues or
to manage her skin
or past acne concerns then i'm really
just so glad that she
found out what works for her there are
thankfully a lot of dairy-free and
gluten-free options nowadays that
can really prevent us from letting
ourselves feel deprived
or creating unnecessary nutritional gaps
in our diet
and sami seems to be getting enough
fiber b
vitamins calcium carbs and protein
elsewhere in her diet
so i really see no harm in limiting or
avoiding these foods
if i really want to get nitpickety
especially because she is a fitness
influencer and athlete
i would just make sure that she's
spacing her protein out throughout the
day
and getting enough carbs in that
post-workout meal
to really optimize recovery now i want
to close off by quickly speaking to
sammy's relationship with food
and any other little tidbits of
information that i picked up on
while watching a bunch of her videos now
in one q a video where she took viewers
through
a day in her life sammy addresses a
question about whether or not she does
cheat meals let's take a look and then
as far as like cheat meals you could say
i don't really call them that but meals
that are not part of like maybe my
healthier options it really just matters
the week so it matters how many social
events i have
but like i'm not thinking about
should i have that say they had a bomb
pizza with like vegan cheese and
gluten-free bread like i'm going for the
pizza you know so it's like those times
are the moments that i think you should
enjoy yourself more
than being so concerned but that's why
i'm 80 20 so throughout the week i'm
really focusing on
choosing those healthier options so that
when the time comes to go to social
events or you don't have the freedom to
have exactly what you want
you don't feel as like oh dang it
because you've been crushing it through
the week
okay so i appreciate that sami doesn't
use the whole
cheat meal language as you guys know
that i just really feel that if we want
to change
our relationship with food language
ultimately
does matter and seeing our diet as
something to be
cheated on is usually a sign that it's
unsustainable and unnecessarily
restrictive
and while i don't think that we need to
use explicit labels like 80 20
which i also just feel like is a bit of
a food rule i get that it's kind of just
a colloquial term for balance
so i get what she means ultimately sammy
is a fitness influencer so
fueling her body with good nutrition is
not only important for her own physical
and emotional health but also in a lot
of ways
for her livelihood as well so it does
make sense to me that she would want to
prioritize
nutrient-dense meals and snacks as often
as she can
it sounds and looks like sammy aims to
eat a nutrient-dense balanced diet when
she's got the physical capacity to
manage that because
you know maybe she's eating at home and
that when she goes out with friends
or just feels like it that she's not
going to deny
herself the pizza or whatever she feels
like
she still sticks to being gluten-free
and dairy-free and maybe
choosing like a gluten-free dairy-free
pizza because again
she's established that consuming those
things
doesn't feel good to her but she's not
stressing over calories or the macros in
that meal
and a lot of people ask me if eating
intuitively or
finding food freedom is possible within
the context of
food restrictions like these and i would
say absolutely
yes if you've collected data and
established that
hey i get really bad gas when i eat
dairy so
that isn't enjoyable to me avoiding
dairy
would probably be the intuitive thing to
do but if you avoid
all pizza including dairy-free
gluten-free
pizza even though you really want it and
you know that it would be an enjoyable
experience for you
you run the very real risk of falling
into
scarcity mentality i also want to
quickly comment on her thoughts of
having dessert
how often do i have cheat meals how
often do i have dessert things of that
sort
i have dessert every single day but when
i have dessert it's
every day is different right so one
night it could be a piece of a chocolate
bar that's
70 cacao it matters the day but really
mostly you guys see i love air pop
popcorn the brand lesser evil
and then i'll pair it with chocolate
chips so i'm always having a dessert
but it's just a healthier option okay so
again
if this is truly what sammy is craving
for dessert then
who am i to judge i don't want to police
people and say
hey your desserts aren't unhealthy
enough because
hey it's a great thing to be craving
veggies and hummus
when i was pregnant i lowkey only
wanted to eat salad and fruit and there
was not even
a single restrictive thought associated
with it at all
it's just what i wanted but i also think
it's always worth doing a deep dive to
ask yourself
is this what i really want or am i just
choosing this because i think i
should want it or because i had like
three brownies yesterday
and now i should be eating healthier
i just think that doing these little
check-ins with yourself to
gauge your intentions is really
important for helping maintain
a strong relationship with food now i
will say that i did hear sam
use the word clean a few times cleaner
clean clean
in this what i in a day video to
describe like a simple ingredient list
which you know is language i don't love
but i also get that it's just so heavily
ingrained in diet culture
that it's hard to escape i also saw in
another video that she was talking about
having celery juice
and that she knows you're supposed to
have juice on an empty stomach
but often doesn't just because she
doesn't want to fire up the juicer so
early in the morning
i mean i'm glad she isn't obsessive
about it to
wake up her whole household for the sake
of pseudoscience but i will just say
that
no you're not losing out on the
nutritional benefits
of celery juice which let's be real
are grossly overstated in wellness
culture by drinking it
later on in the day most people use
celery juice as a laxative first thing
in the morning
the same way that you know a lot of
other people use coffee
but if you're consuming a balanced diet
that's rich in water and fiber
as sammy does you probably shouldn't
need to rely on
things like celery juice anyway so if
you really like celery juice for some
reason
you can rest assured that you can drink
it
whenever you want i also want to just
mention that i watched sami's video on
her journey to healing her acne
and she did mention that one of the
first professionals that she saw
who was a hormone specialist as she
called her
put her on a medication called
spironolactone
to help block the testosterone that was
thought to be contributing to
her acne so spironolactone is actually
often used for supporting transgender
women
because it helps lower one's natural
testosterone levels
and sami was quite transparent that it
caused her to lose a
ton of weight because it's also a known
diuretic
and it sucked the life out of her as she
said now sammy did mention that this
practitioner never even did a proper
history or work up on sammy
or else she probably would have
hopefully known
that it wasn't a good option for her as
a fitness professional
but then sammy suggested it was her
fault for not doing more research
herself on the medication before she
took
it now i just have to say that it's
really sad to me that sammy
would blame herself for you know the
poor patient care that she received here
the onus really shouldn't be on the
patient or client to have
to do like a ton of research on any kind
of medication or supplement to determine
if it's right for them we're not the
doctors so i think it's a really good
reminder
that if a healthcare provider is not
asking
a ton of questions before prescribing a
medication or supplement
it may be time to seek out another
opinion and i'm not talking about the
internet's opinion
i'm talking about finding another
professional who
understands your unique case please
remember
that if a product whether that's a
pharmaceutical product or a natural
health supplement
has any impact on your body it is not
benign
and as a result it therefore has the
power
to potentially cause harm but ultimately
i'm so glad that sammy has found a
solution for her acne that's
working for her without causing undue
harm
so with all of that said i was
pleasantly surprised by
sammy's channel outside the clean eating
language
i didn't hear a ton of demonizing of
food and outside of her health-related
diet restrictions
i didn't see her cutting out or
restricting foods i also think her
workouts
look bomb and she's just really pleasant
to listen to and watch
so if you're looking for a fitness
influencer that isn't grossly
restricting
definitely give sami's content a watch
also a big shout out to ava's mana for
sponsoring this video again
don't forget to check out the link in
the description below if you want to
download the game yourself
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
if you guys liked it be sure to give it
the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you
would like to see in review next
subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye